hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes art and makes
it slug it out in glorious battle i'm
your host mark ellis and while some
others may find it intimidating to take
a bunch of beloved characters from
popular franchises and toss them into a
pit of competitive fury not this guy
i could do this all day i understood
that reference i won't because i also
have naps to take and a dog to walk but
the three heroes we have on the program
they have no problem fighting against
villains government regulations even
each other from time to time because we
have iron man against captain america
against thor also known as tony stark
versus steve rogers versus
thor
johnson what's his just thor son of odin
you had one joe in one corner you have
the billionaire playboy but enough about
me let's meet tony stark whiz kid turned
weapons magnate turned superhero after
near-death experience in a cave stark
became iron man and was not shy about
letting the world know who he really was
thor didn't really have an alter ego
mainly because that one ego plenty big
enough he's the god of thunder who loves
his homeworld of asgard more than just
about anything else except possibly his
sweetheart jane or the raccoon he refers
to as a sweet rabbit
and then we have steve rogers a scrappy
scrawny kid from brooklyn who wanted to
fight for his country and ended up being
a thawed out popsicle that helped save
the entire universe from snappy
destruction man are we really doing this
this is gonna be fun and the comment
section
oh boy do i get a suit of armor i feel
like i need one ah here's how we'll
determine a winner round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three iconic moments round
four
subscriptions and then we'll do a wild
card round that somehow is even more
secretive than round four it's a
particularly exciting time to be talking
about these mcu heroes past and present
as we look to the future with sweaty
anticipation for thor love and thunder
but as of this moment each one of our
fellows in competition today have
exactly one trilogy to their name as
well as a bunch of little team-ups and
film series called the avengers black
widow got a cool spin-off movie hawkeye
had a fun streaming show and soon enough
we'll get to see hulk teach his cousin
that it ain't easy being green but today
it's all good old-fashioned ogmcu
battles for all the marbles
even if certain competitors may not be
able to physically receive their
trophies anymore let's get it on round
one box office since the late 1960s
every so often we'd get a comic book
movie hitting the big screen and for the
most part audiences would get very
excited batman was a hoot in 1966
superman was a giant leap forward in
1978 and in 1989 batman once again
dominated the summer x-men and
spider-man kicked off the new millennium
with a bang honorable mention to blade
as well but then in 2008 the summer
launched with a jericho missile-sized
event iron man debuted that may and by
the end of that first weekend he wasn't
just a b character with an a theme song
anymore much like when black sabbath hit
the music scene when the world saw
robert downey jr as tony stark slash
iron man the landscape of cinema was
changed forever or at least until we
reboot the whole thing
iron man 1 would go on to gross 585
million dollars across the globe then
iron man 2 would tax 621 million bucks
more onto the total iron man 3 would
then surpass the hallowed 1 billion line
notching a total of 1.2 bill oh in
between part 2 and 3 some talky called
the avengers hit and earned a tidy 1.5
billion it was a fun movie to be at so
stark for all of his movies that he's
ever made an appearance in has grossed
12.2 billion dollars worldwide but for
our purposes today let's focus on his
trilogy the numbers are still more than
capable of buying a few american
cheeseburger restaurants 2.4 billion
dollars total making for a per metal guy
movie average of 807 million dollars
every time we hear ac dc thor would be
up next in chronological order both in
terms of movie release dates and i think
he's like a hundred years older than cap
it's hilarious anywho april 2011 saw the
asgardian hunk fall to earth gross 449
million dollars and alert us that hey
we're building something pretty
profitable here thor the dark world was
next in his trilogy and it would go on
to earn 644 million dollars then thor
ragnarok antlered its way to a grand
master approved
850 million bones in milky way dollars
that gives t-dog an almost 2 billion
total making for a perfect average of
648 million we got us a ball game here
captain america showed up to battle the
nazis in the summer of 2011 and if you
think he was a little late the movie is
a period piece he wanted to serve his
country in world war ii there was only
one problem he looked more like squints
from the sand lot than a soldier quiet
but we showed up nevertheless and
injected the box office with super serum
to the tune of 370 million dollars
worldwide really the lowest grossing
kickoff of the three
huh well don't worry pal once we got
your buckaroo bucky into the sequel in a
um
more prominent role that flick did 714
million dollars mainly on the strength
of just how menacing robert redford can
be towards housekeeping then cap had a
third movie a little ditty called civil
war and it earned a whopping 1.15
billion bucks across the i know what
you're thinking hey mark you absolute
stud didn't iron man really help out
with that box office total yeah he did
and so did spider-man and black panther
and ant boy it was a huge party but it
was technically thrown by captain
america not only is that the best
shindig a geriatric has ever tossed but
it also suddenly makes this round get a
little squeezier cap's trilogy has
hauled in a total of 2.23 billion
dollars making for a per movie average
of 746 million iron man was sitting on
his throne thor knocked on the door and
cap almost blew the house down but even
if we ignored the fact that iron man was
heavily involved in the marketing for
civil war tony stark still emerges as
the all-time breadwinner amongst these
three folks he wins round one but don't
go getting cocky and challenging that
arachnid kid from the bronx in a box
office contest it won't end well but
today iron man gets on the board first
and goes up one to nothing to nothing
round two tomato meter slash audience
score alright so as impressive as those
gaudy box office numbers may be we've
seen comic book films crushed the bo for
generations the real trick is having
those sequels hold up to the original
not in terms of dollars and cents but in
critical reaction don't believe me well
first of all that hurts my feelings
secondly remember how everyone loved
superman in 1978 well superman 4 the
quest for peace rests at just 10
on the tomato meter batman 1989 sure was
beloved but batman and robin 12
on the tm i freeze i'm batman so this
round that's all about how critics and
audiences felt about your product after
they forked over the cash will be won by
which superhero can maintain the
momentum from their first hit the most
or maybe even hit that nitrous boost for
the sequels made popular by those fast
and very angry movies let's kick off
with your previous round's winner iron
man who'd probably win a few street
races with all that muscle in his garage
as for tomato meter flexing tony's got
that too the first iron man flick is 94
which ties it with avengers end game
iron man 2 dropped down to 72 percent
and uh oh this is what happens i warned
you all luckily iron man 3 rebounded and
found solid fresh territory with a 79
something magical is happening for cap
it was a steady climb upwards starting
things off within 79 for the first
avenger from there the winter soldier
rose to 90
and civil war maintained the pace by
tying it at 90 percent that's an a minus
and can definitely get you into nyu if
your extracurriculars are up to par does
anyone have any orange slices so cap
sports an 86 percent average for his
trilogy meanwhile
tone bear can i call mr stark that
clings to an 81.6 average on the tomato
meter the door is open but is it wide
enough for thor to stroll through the
first thor is fresh at 77 percent the
second thor fell to 66
and i told you it's happening again
don't worry ragnarok turned it all
around and notched a 92 on the tomato
meter so every flick in every one of
these trilogies is fresh although thor
brings up the rear with a 78.3
average for his trifecta
it's slightly better news on the
audience score metric for the fella who
doth wear mother's drapes as he climbs
to 79.3
pinning him in a virtual deadlock with
iron man who averages 80 percent even
with audiences but we just seem to love
that all-american 95 year old the most
don't you say left come on
cap's audience score average is a
sterling 85
on the strength of the winner's soldier
with its 93
meanwhile the high audience bar for iron
man is the og at 91
and thor's best effort is with ragnarok
and it's 87
so captain america has the best averages
for both tomato meter and audience score
and he might have been able to pull off
a win here without civil war
come on man but come on that airplane
tarmac sequence was pretty sick i hate
travel toys but i miss my connection to
watch that play out
from a safe distance captain america
gets the win in the tomato meter slash
audience score round and gets his first
point of the day hey
let's hear it for captain america
[Applause]
[Music]
round three iconic moments
if i had a nickel for every time one of
these heroes did something cool amazing
stupendous or just said something
braggadocious i would cease to be mark
ellis and would become scrooge mcduck
between them these boys have nine movies
solely dedicated to showing off their
heroic nature in the face of incredible
odds imposing villains and let's be
honest you gotta do it before any of the
other super beings beat you to the punch
but who has the most best all-time
sweetest iconic moments a premium will
be placed on your solo film efforts but
i'll let a few infinity game kind of
sequences slide in there as well get
this man shield
from the get-go tony stark let us know
exactly who he was what he cared about
and how far his journey to becoming a
beloved superhero would be his
introduction mirrors that of the jericho
missile itself like the explosion it
creates its manufacturer is bold
bombastic and leaves one needing a drink
immediately after witnessing it the
missile's cool the fact that stark
brings a mobile booze cart to the
proceedings is ingenious thor makes a
grand entrance as well in the throne
room during the early going of his very
first film but for me it was the rain
fight scene that really showed us the
might of this brawny brawler and for
comedic relief like no earthling could
possibly pull off thor marching into a
pet store and demanding a horse is an
all-timer i need a horse
we don't have horses steve rogers intro
is more along the lines of that is
captain america how many protein shakes
we would watch this poor guy chug before
that happens jesus
somebody get that kid his sandwich but
then the super serum kicks in and
immediately we realize that the scrappy
kid is now capable of electrifying chase
scenes okay let me give that kid a shine
though i do applaud him for jumping on
the tommy lee jones grenade when
everyone else ducked in fear thor
continues kicking ass in the dark world
particularly if you make your living as
a rock monster meanwhile in iron man 2
tony goes from [ __ ] of the wok to scared
chicken in the road when he's confronted
with the ominous presence of whiplash
while the world watches on in horror see
that's a problem with being a big famous
superhero folks are going to see you at
your best and your worst but whereas the
second entry for both iron man and thor
weren't their shiniest moments the
winter soldier was a bold step forward
for both captain america now in modern
times and the mcu in terms of crafting a
spy thriller disguised as a comic book
flick the elevator fight is the single
best fracas of its kind since john
mcclane asked for the winning lottery
numbers in die hard with a vengeance and
it's nuts to witness the turn of robert
redford he went from guy who's bffs with
sam jackson's nick fury to literally the
worst person in the world yeah
yeah i still love when he hits the big
home run in the natural it's also super
weird to see my boy gary shandling
whisper hail hydra hashtag not my larry
sanders say we want about iron man 3 and
it's hilarious
twist hey it's complicated nice it's
complicated but the sheer amount of iron
folk we get in that movie is
scintillating but for me it's the tender
moments that make the film a winner tony
opening up to rhodey about his very real
ptsd after the battle of new york and
iron man bonding with a random kid who
ends up growing on him civil war acts as
a sort of avenger film all by itself but
the headlining match is one i still
can't believe i got to witness cat
versus iron man i still maintain that if
that's just tony versus cap stark wins
but then got that pesky winter soldier
that always show up to wreck a
billionaire's day don't believe me just
ask tony's dad too soon
thor ragnarok is by far the most
highlight stacked of his three solo
ventures thanks in large green part to
hulk the friend from workline ranks
among the best in comic book movie
history and thor and loki also have so
much to work out as they try to better
their own situations in the process if i
was to give one honorary point for an
avengers movie i'd love nothing more
than to give thor his roses for the
sweet rabbit line that's how i refer to
molly the wonder dog now but i can't
shortchange the god of thunder's arrival
into wakanda just in the nick of time in
infinity war as always led zeppelin is
your soundtrack pretty helpful cap also
has his share of comedic highlights
referring to his own posterior in the
most um patriotic way imaginable in
endgame that is america's ass
but why do we show up to the movies to
watch biceps stymy helicopters civil war
took the cake until capp took milner for
those famous fighting words in avengers
end game this thing really isn't that
heavy i could actually do this all day
but
dropped it
you're all not worthy enhanced of course
by the moment in age of ultron when even
thor noticed just how much time cap's
been putting in the gym but then we find
ourselves returning back to tony his
endgame moments feature plenty of comedy
and familial tones but his snap with the
infinity gauntlet and once more saying
exactly who he is is the icing on the
best cake any british bake off fan could
hope for and i
and
iron man
he went out the same way he came in with
a gigantic explosion that would alter
the course of comic book films
forevermore and for those efforts and
all the guffaws in between stark wins
the point and goes back up two to one to
nothing round four magazine
subscriptions
and now that head scratching round title
gets some clarity mark why not one
magazine or one magazine subscription
well because between these three heroes
they have a lot of issues family friends
significant others thor iron man and cap
have a ton of emotional weight to
negotiate through their runs this round
will be won by whoever has the most to
deal with and who's taken the most steps
to improve the mental health of
themselves and their inner circle
captain america seems like the all
united states boy of a bygone era and
indeed at one time he was but even then
he had to manage his dreams against the
very limiting means his body would allow
once the super serum process was
complete he still had a maniacal
compulsion to serve his country only to
be shelved as a uso traveling sideshow
instead of actually jumping into the
fire then his life is further
complicated by falling for a gown named
peggy a badass in her own right only to
find himself thought out in another time
when peg is um
still alive that's the good news but uh
yeah she makes ma from golden girls look
like a spring chicken
yes i think it works meanwhile at
stark's place he has everything one
could possibly want in a supportive
partner but he was too busy playboying
around town and building bombs to notice
those fun goop candles in his office
even after he sorts out who he actually
should be in a far away cave tony still
can't fully commit to pepper until it's
almost too late but long before miss
potts entered the picture tony's parents
had a premature exit stark's last words
with his folks weren't the ideal phrases
given the tragedy that was about to
ensue and even with all the iron in the
world the man inside the suit was still
haunted by how they left things if it's
daddy issues you won how about we toss
in some mommy ones and a sibling rivalry
at no extra charge that's what thor is
dealing with throughout his own trilogy
and it makes for a gruff exterior that
no one not named jane foster can truly
crack
[Music]
sorry now imagine having all of that and
then putting the pressure of
representing an entire planet while
trying to save its people on your
shoulders if tony and thor were tied
with parent troubles loki is the
ultimate trickster serves as a constant
thorn in the side of his bro oh and then
their sister returns to bring the
freaking apocalypse to their home planet
how do you get through all this in one
session with your therapist my father is
dead
as are the princes you're welcome and
yeah tony stark had to step up and
completely change the course of his
billion-dollar company but thor's
enterprise was asgard itself and he also
lost an eye i had to say it of the three
cap seems to have wrapped things up in
the most fairytale fashion he helped
save the known universe then returned to
his homeworld in the time that he was
most fond of back in the day with his
steady girl peggy by the time he ages
into the modern world this time the only
fight he's getting in is for the last
piece of prime rib at hometown buffet no
i'd like a bloody mary in a round that
comes down to tony and thor i give stark
points for stepping up when we needed
him the most the ultimate selfish dude
had matured into a man who could make
the ultimate sacrifice for the greater
good but even when he was a guy
supposedly at peace with his pepper and
their daughter in a remote cabin there
was still an air of unfinished business
he was able to at least rise above his
own daddy issues to be a great papa who
loves his girl infinity and was the
perfect mentor for peter parker but thor
has had more of a mountain to climb than
anyone both him and stark were born into
privilege but throughout his life it
feels like thor never had it easy
brother sister mom dad asgard as a whole
his eyeball so dead brother huh
yeah it could be annoying just because
thor still has some soul searching to do
doesn't mean that he loses points rather
we should all applaud him for sticking
around when a heroic sacrifice or a
relationship at a time would have been
the easier way out the dude is still
looking out for us and by the way tony
when thor found his romantic match he
made his feelings clearer than you did
way early thor takes the issues round
even though his magazine has yet to be
completed everyone's on the board now
but it's still iron man 2 god of thunder
and cap want a piece not the best you
can do
and now it's time for the wild card
round snap crackle pop as much as i'd
love to see these three muddy heroes
take on the culinary experts at rice
krispies ooh do i smell another versus
episode next season we could do a whole
serial mascot bracket i got tony the
tiger i like it this particular crackle
and pop refer to the many baddies that
iron man captain crunch i mean america
and thor have had to battle and the snap
well you'll get extra points for how you
handled that matchup with thanos kicking
things off with tony stark who we met in
a simpler time in the marvel cinematic
universe there was no known multiverse
and we didn't have strange doctors
caping around town just a couple
corporate magnates arguing with their
robot machines as to how a company
should be run obadistain was a good
warm-up for whiplash and justin hammer
and they were good practice for mandarin
who was actually uh there was a lot of
competition aldrich killian was there
that's my final answer i am the mandarin
thor had to deal with his own nefarious
adopted brother loki multiple times oh
and he also had to tussle with a frost
giant and a destroyer and that's all in
one movie then he took on a dark elf
which is much scarier than it sounds and
a delicious brewski around christmas
time but the creme de la creme as far as
imposing opposition was of course hella
whose antlers resembled the top of the
food chain hell bent on chomping
everything and anything on asgard he
also fought hulk a few times which is
really the best training camp there is
but if it's fights among brothers
preparing for a long winter we're not
talking about the nfl preseason rather
it's the love lost between bucky and
steve winter soldier and captain america
cap wanted nothing more than to keep his
war buddy by his side but those
nefarious evildoers love their tricky
word combinations say the random phrase
in the right order and all the wrong
stuff happens so much so that cap's
primary foe in winter soldier became
tony's biggest adversary along with cap
in civil war if you're keeping score at
home so far thor has the upper hand so
now we look to that almighty paw of
thanos the biggest baddie the avengers
ever had to tango with took a multitude
of films and a freaking time machine to
be felt but thor had a clear shot at him
and that gauntlet at hand however he
went for the chest
it's a fair mistake in the moment we all
probably would have done it but you got
to cut the head off a snake or at least
the hand with the infinity gauntlet on
it come on thor you gotta know time and
situation
captain america did surprise thanos when
he grabbed onto that hand in infinity
war and the purple gym god did look
impressed either with cap's strength
sheer guts or both but it was tony stark
who earned verbal praise from thanos at
the end of infinity war which is good
sportsmanship and twas iron man who
ultimately did the snap that ended
grimace's reign of terror for good it
was heroic necessary and a fitting end
to tony stark service as one of the
leaders of the avengers and for that and
so much more along the way tony stark
gets the point and thus wins the match
three to one to one
i know it was so tough voting against
cap and thor but come on iron man is the
first one we fell in love with for a
reason and by the way if you like iron
man on versus he took on batman last
season it was a good one well that's all
the time we have today and keep in mind
this is all just my opinion now let's
hear from you hit me up on social media
at mark ellis live and keep it right
here at rotten tomatoes for all the
latest in the world of movies tv
entertainment and so much more thanks
for watching versus my name is mark
ellis and i will now go home to pet my
sweet rabbit
which is what i call it hi maui
[Applause]
you